but i mean like you said it was a lot of
fun because i mean it sounds like you
were watching
well you know fun from the perspective
of excitement and fulfillment with what
you're doing i mean it's never fun to
watch somebody die on a
screen but you mentioned that you
watched a lot of um
you know drone strikes and stuff like
that like how much of that can you talk
about
uh just kind of wake up i mean i um i
got to interact with all the partners
you would assume somebody in that role
would
interact with and really loved it like
the fbi
dod and other government agencies all
have like their own pretty unique
culture
and um getting to be in the middle of
basically the food fight between all
these agencies
and you know getting to deal with you
know knowing okay that guy
like who i just had coffee with is
hunting the number one terrorist in the
world or
you know this uh you know my co-worker
literally just found
you know a plot inside the united states
through an op she was running like that
sort of stuff
is uh there's really no way to describe
that but it's really fulfilling
but at the same time if there's no
promotion potential and
um you know you're working your ass off
you're working christmas
and um you literally like i mean i
calculated i maybe had 200
left after uh you know after i had paid
my bills
to you know go out on a date or you know
spend that on
you know just close or you know
eventually save up for a nice watch or
something like that
and no matter how good the actual work
was at least for me it was just
corrosive
like i uh my stress level was up here 90
of the time and um started to feel the
health effects of that too
what's that show that they ran on
netflix for a while with that fbi
um profiler that check she's always
wigged out and on medications
uh what is it uh blacklist or are you um
is this uh homeland
homeland that's it yeah is that like is
that a fairly accurate representation of
what guys can expect if they
start working with that agency there's a
scene in the start of season five in
homeland where they're all sitting in
the basement of the cia and talking
about
how isis is sneaking into europe and i
like it was funny watching that because
i had literally been in that conference
room like a day
before so they actually use the actual
conference room like the set
uh so jack ryan that show actually used
the cis headquarters building a little
bit for philippine
but um but for uh a lot of homeland that
was filmed in south carolina and it's
uh some of it's just dumb so for example
they mentioned big
like roads that are huge in northern
virginia like uh four or five lane
highway
and two-lane road in the show so a lot
of that
and a lot of the tradecraft and a lot of
the storyline is pretty wacky for
homeland but
homeland season five is super accurate
like that that was pretty close to real
life
you